- How are you?
- I'm good.
I'm so good.
- It's good to see you.
- You like a new mama?
- I'm a new mama.
Yeah.
I mean, not that new.
- They're still clapping.
That does not usually happen.
Get it.
- [Mandy] Thanks guys.
- That does not usually happen.
That is the power of Mandy Moore.
No, you're a new mama
now, so that's exciting.
- I am, yeah.
- Are you just
in heaven smelling baby?
- I mean, he's about to turn
one, so I'm like slowly.
I know.
There he is.
- [Kelly] Geez.
(laughs)
- A little Gus.
Yeah, he's almost one.
So I'm kind of like
migrating out of babydom
into toddlerdom and-
- Yeah.
- It's wild.
- [Kelly] It's just gonna get more wild.
(laughs)
- I know.
- Says the woman with a
five and seven year old.
No, but you named him Gus,
but it's August, right?
- It's August, yeah.
- So was there some, something
about the month of August?
Is that why you?
- August is when we found out
that we were having a boy.
And, um yeah, it's also the
month that my husband was born.
So we just-
And we love the name, Gus.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause my husband's
last name is Goldsmith
and I like being an alliterative name.
Mandy Moore.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we wanted
to have a G, G.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Kelly Clarkson. River Rose.
- Right?
- Yeah, my kids are like
that, I like alliteration.
Yeah.
- It's fun.
Yeah, so is.
- It's great for monogramming.
It's also nice for that.
No, but what's the hardest part you think
that you didn't see coming?
Like being a mama?
There's probably a lot.
- I mean, I don't even
know where to begin,
and all of it?
It's it is every cliche in the book.
Right? For those parents out there
like life went from CPR
to technicolor like that.
I mean it's just the most overwhelming.
All consuming love.
And it's funny 'cause
I've been playing a mom
on a television show for six
years and I'm like, wait,
can we go back to the beginning now?
Because I know what it's like to be a mom.
I've been faking it.
- I am so method right now
in it.
Was that hard though to play a mom
like not being a mom?
'Cause I did hear Milo out
do a bit whenever he was here
'cause he said I had to teach her
how to do our first diaper.
- [Mandy] Oh yeah.
- Like change a fight
and you didn't know how to,
because you now have a kid.
- I yeah.
And I just, my husband and I
neither of us really had
any experience with babies.
- [Kelly] Me neither, before I had one.
- So I just remember having
to lean on Milo so hard
especially in the beginning of the show.
- Which Milo doesn't have children.
- He doesn't have children,
but he has nieces and nephews.
- I have nieces and nephews
and I still had never changed
a diaper before my children.
- Milo's just missed.
- That's your baby's
butt, take care your own.
I was like, I didn't make anybody do mine.
- He's showing me how to
swaddle, how to change diapers.
- He's so good at that, okay.
- He was incredible.
And even this was like the first season.
And then I remember
right before I gave birth to
Gus last year, same thing.
It was like we were shooting
a scene where we had to like
change and I'm like, I'm
about to do this in real life.
And I have no idea what I'm doing.
- Oh my God.
No, it's like that for everybody.
I did hear that you had an
interesting first plane ride.
- Yeah, so I took my first flight with him
when he was about four months old.
And I remember being
terrified, like any new parent
that he was just gonna cry.
And I didn't wanna upset anybody
or ruffle feathers, but no
we didn't have to worry about that.
He was a fantastic
passenger, but he had two
gigantic blowouts,
like the pressure just
cleared all the plumbing out.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I thought we had
brought enough diapers
and enough changes of
clothes and we didn't.
- Oh no.
- No, I mean we barely made it
to where we had like a layover somewhere.
And then when we got to our
layover, we had to do the
the frantic scramble to like
a new stand and buy the little
- And you start getting resourceful.
This will happen, when you're like
in the car and that
happens, you're like great,
the second pair of clothing,
nobody put it back in the bag.
And you're like, what?
And then you start
pulling things in your car
and you're like I guess
I'll never see you again.
And you're like, putting it on your trial.
It's yeah. It's fun.
I heard that Hillary Duff,
did she host like an
entertainment play date?
Like what happened with your kids?
What happened?
- Well Hillary is a, is a close friend
and she has a daughter who is
six weeks younger than Gus.
And she's like super mom.
She has three kids
but she decided to start
hosting this music class
at her house.
And there's lots of other
new moms in our group,
Megan trainer and Ashley Tisdale.
So it kind of became like a bit of a thing
but there's lots of other
people that have lots
of other jobs in this
class, but it's so much fun.
Like I think in this time
of COVID and you know
having a kid in the midst of a pandemic
like finding community to lean on.
- [Kelly] 100%
- And be able to like have your kids
sort of start to grow up
together, but also like.
- And have those pods where your kids
can play with other kids.
- For sure is so essential.
So I'm really grateful that
Hillary has done us all this,
this giant favor.
- Yeah, 'cause It's a lot,
to host something like that.
Yeah, that's like.
Especially a mom of three.
Get it Hillary Duff.
- I know.
- She's trying to make us look bad, Mandy.
- She does it all, for sure.
- Your character on this
show has three kids.
So you were also one of three, right?
I was too.
Were you middle?
- [Mandy] I'm Middle.
- I'm last born.
Yeah.
But you were the only girl?
- [Kelly] I, yes.
- So that's different.
- Are you?
- No, two girls.
- Oh.
- But we were like seven years apart.
Seven and a half years apart.
So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But that is that hard
growing up with two boys?
- No, I mean, I feel like I was super
I had two super protective
brothers on either side.
- [Kelly] My God.
- Kind of like the show
in, in a weird way.
It sort of like echoes the show, but.
- My brother used to pin me down
and do that spit thing
and suck it back up on.
We had different childhoods Mandy,
like wait.
So that's kind of cool though.
How the show was.
- Yeah, it's kind of like
echoes of my childhood, but
but yeah, I get to live it out
as their mother and I'm the
youngest one in the cast.
It's all very strange.
- (giggles) Does, have you
ever actually come home
with the like older Rebecca step on
and your baby be like, who are you?
- No, but he's come to visit me on set.
He has been hanging out with me
since he was a month old on set
and it is slightly confusing.
Although I argue
I have to give him some
reason to go to therapy later.
So, but yeah, he kind of like
I think he hears my
voice and he smells me.
So he knows it's me.
But like, you know, I have a wig on
on top of that and all this
like prosthetic makeup.
Yeah, he was my little
makeup artist that day.
- Look at his face.
He is such a beautiful bay.
Oh my gosh.
- He is confused.
But you know, he's gotta
get used to it, it's my job.
- Yeah, to lean in.
Yeah.
Well, one of your movies,
"A walk to remember",
which is one of my sister's
personal favorite movies of all time.
It turns 20 this year.
- Yeah.
- Which, I'm a little upset
about that you look the same.
- Your, Kelly.
- You're you're like
some of us changed Mandy
and some of us just go in some cryo,
like, I don't know what happens
but you look like you looked
and like there, but it's crazy.
- You're kind.
- No, it's a great skincare regimen.
- I was a baby and that's
a nice fuzzy picture.
(laughing)
- Thank God for old like Polaroids.
Yeah, no, I, I turn 17 on that movie.
It is wild that it's 20 years old.
It's wild that people still
connect with that movie.
It still resonates clearly.
Like, I like being a part of projects
that make people cry.
- [Kelly] No, but you with a message.
- Yeah, no it's a great message.
- Yeah.
- For sure.
- It's beautiful.
And 17 being a lead.
I would, that is, seems
like a little nervous.
I'd be a little nervous.
- I didn't what I was doing,
thank goodness.
- [Kelly] So, that's good.
- My, my co-star Shane West,
like had to introduce me
how to hit a mark.
You know, there, you,
you were supposed to like
hit your mark to make sure
you're in the right camera position.
I would like walk up to
my mark and look down
like a total amateur.
I don't know.
It was my first like onscreen kiss.
I mean, it was everything.
- Is it? Okay.
My first kiss was
technically on stage too,
in like a musical in like high school.
And I was like, this is
not how I pictured it.
This was everyone's watching.
It was really uncomfortable.
- You get like the awkwardness
out of the way maybe.
And then there's like less pressure
when it happens in real life.
- Nah, then when it really
happened, it was gross.
Yeah, he was like searching for something.
I was like, there's nothing in
you're not gonna find anything.
It was just really uncomfortable.
Yeah, all the first kiss is there.
They ruin me.
But, but people don't realize
if you're like an entertainment industry
or some form like that
could be your first kiss.
And mine was on stage, it was awkward.
- It was, yeah, it was definitely awkward
but I also really liked it.
I mean, you're like getting
to kiss a handsome boy,
there's no way that boy
would kiss me on real life.
- I had known this boy
since like childhood,
now he's like a brother.
I was like, I guess.
- [Mandy] Not a great choice.
- Not a, yeah, uncomfortable.
Well, now you're in the
final season of "This is us".
So what's going on with
your character, Rebecca.
- Whoa, wait to bring it down.
My, so we're tying up, you know
over a hundred episodes of
this show and telling the story
of this family and my character
at present day.
Obviously I, I play this woman
from 25 to 85 in present day.
She's dealing with
dementia, with Alzheimer's.
So it's, it's quite heartbreaking
but I love that we're able
to have this conversation
and hopefully destigmatize the
conversation around Alzheimer
and including the family and
all of the, the decisions that
like everyone is a unit
collectively has to make together.
But it's, I, I'm so excited that we get
to sort of wrap up this story
and in a really beautiful way.
And I think people are gonna be happy
with us the way we stick
the landing as it were.
- Yeah, is it?
I have a question 'cause is it hard to
snap out of that when you leave work
'cause y'all do cover so
many serious situations
and scenarios within family dynamics.
Is that hard to like
compartmentalize when you go home?
- I think like for me, especially
in this particular situation,
like I grieve for my character.
My character is very intentional.
She's very stoic.
She has so much grace
the way she's sort of
handling this diagnosis.
And I, as Mandy have to not
let my feelings for her,
my, my sadness, my grief,
like kind of bleed into the performance.
So it's like I'll sometimes
leave, set and get back,
you know to my trailer in
my car and just like, ugh,
like it's a really, it's
an emotional release
but also like there's so much levity
in between takes, everybody's
so funny on the show.
Like we do find ways
to sort of like crack jokes in between
'cause otherwise it
would be a horrible work.
- Everybody's just sad.
- Exactly, just crying all the time.
So yeah, we have to find
a way to like liven it up.
- Yeah, I love your cast.
We've had almost everybody on here,
it's, we love your cast.
- It's the cast remarkable
group of people I feel
so lucky that I've been
like spent the last six
years of my life with them.
I love them so deeply.
- That's awesome.
- They're the best.
- Well, what has it meant to you
that y'all shown so much
diversity on the show?
Especially within a
family, like one family.
- Yeah, like the family dynamics,
but what a family can look like.
I mean, I'm so grateful again
that we've had the opportunity
that people have been
interested in the show
from the very beginning.
And have kind of come along on this
this journey with us
for the last six years.
Like I think it's,
the conversations we've
been able to elicit
are so important.
Yeah, it's been the greatest gift
to be a part of something
that's so cathartic
and emotional and also reflective of,
even though there's so much specificity
in who these people are in
these different stories,
like people are still able
to see themselves in it
and that's such a gift.
- Yeah, that is a gift.
Be a part of something that means, yeah.
- [Mandy] That means something to people.
- Well, thank you so much
Mandy, we love having you on.
- Thank you, is so good to see you.
- You can see the final
season of "This is us"
Tuesdays on NBC.